[Music]
right now infamous Clinton dirty dossier
was the single key piece of evidence
that was used in for FISA applications
by the FBI in order to spy on Trump
campaign associate and of course the
president-elect and now the president
Donald Trump without the dossier there
would be no FISA warrant against Carter
page you'll join us in a few minutes
this is an irrefutable fact and of
course we all know that this dirty
dossier was created by a former foreign
spy
Christopher Steele who ultimately really
was paid by Hillary Clinton and the DNC
all to dig up dirt and lies on Donald
Trump in other words it was political
Opry Search filled with all things
Russian lies that even steel himself has
admitted was totally unverified and
uncorroborated and he even said at best
it was raw intelligence and only had a
50/50 chance of being true most of which
has now been totally debunk and yet it
was passed off to you the American
people and FISA Court judges as real
credible evidence by top FBI DOJ
officials to obtain the FISA warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign associate at
the height of a presidential election in
2016 this is a national disgrace this is
an abhorrent abuse of power and very
dangerous to our constitutional republic
all in attempt to turn the full force of
your government against one person and
of course the people that support him
Donald Trump with a vengeance and this
by the way all after top officials
literally rigged the investigation to
save Hillary Clinton from certain
indictments what warranted indictments
necessary indictments if we have equal
justice under the law an equal
application of our laws so tonight it's
time we call on everybody to demand the
release of all 589 pages of these FISA
documents unredacted
and of course our god-given rights as
Americans are now on the line here if we
are to remain a free society
now the mainstream media filled with all
opinion there's no journalism on these
so-called news channels they're supposed
to be investigating our government
holding them accountable and they're
nowhere to be found the biggest story in
their lives they've totally missed it
and meanwhile everything we've been
reporting for well over a year has now
been confirmed for you instead you've
got the media carrying water for their
beloved Barack Obama in other words
finishing the job they did eight
consecutive years of kissing his ass why
should they stop now and as we speak
they are in full-on freakout mode that
several former high-ranking deep state
government bureaucrats all who
propagated these Russian lies found in
Hillary's bought and paid for dossier
might actually lose their precious
security clearances so this week rightly
the Trump administration announced it
was literally looking to strip
top-secret government access from all
those deep state actors you see on your
screen including clapper and Brennan and
rice
Michael Hayden and yeah James Comey and
Andrew McCabe and now predictably
Democrats and the media they are once
again peddling this move from President
Trump as another oh my gosh
earth-shattering feign outrage moment
unprecedented abuse of power in other
words their typical daily donald trump
freakout we've got the video proof take
a look the president wants to silence
his critics period and maybe he thinks
this is a way to do it maybe he can say
well they don't know what they're
talking about if they don't have
clearance anymore
the idea that the president would be
revoking security clearance not based on
wrongdoing just based on words ashamed
I'm not comfortable with vindictiveness
because to me that's very dictator he
represents the office of the presidency
of the United States this threat sounds
more like he leads Turkey or the
Philippines not like he leads the United
States of America let's be honest what
this is about Willie this is an abuse of
executive power this is this is rwan
story
this is not what the United States of
America should be this is so
extraordinary the last thing you want in
intelligence is partisanship
make no mistake that's the only thing
this is about is a cowardly action of
someone who is afraid of criticism by
the way the last guy is the biggest liar
in the country did it ever occur to
these people why a former official no
longer employed by the government would
still have top-secret clearance they
supposedly cares so much about the
dangers of Russia Russia Hillary Clinton
paid for these Russian lies in what is
nothing but a disinformation propaganda
campaign to manipulate the minds of the
American people and steal an election
and the deep state helped her every
single step of the way is that not abuse
of power you don't see the danger in
this and then you're seeing the media
the Democrats sticking up for the most
corrupt people they're swamped friends
that abuse the power that we gave them
we the people for example one time CIA
director John Brennan hates Donald Trump
he's allowed to he's the former
communist how he ever became the CIA
director is unbelievable to me he's also
currently a paid hack over a conspiracy
TV MSNBC which is so appropriate but
during his time as the CIA director
Brennan actually leaked the contents of
this dossier before the election to then
Senator Harry Reid who then subsequently
alerted the public in an open letter to
James Comey really the CIA director
sounds like Pravda sounds like the KGB
after stepping down a CIA director John
Brennan took all of his hatred publicly
on cable news getting paid even which is
okay even calling the sitting president
the United States a traitor really this
guy who leaked the Russian lies what's
this I think there's a big question
first of all in terms of those who are
on mr. Trump's national security team
whether they can continue to serve in
good conscience an individual who
basically betrayed his nation what mr.
Trump did yesterday was to betray
women men of the FBI the CIA NSA and
others and to betray the American public
and that's why I used the term that this
is nothing short of treasonous because
it is a betrayal of the nation he is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy and
it needs to stop and mr. Trump needs to
understand that there gonna be
consequences for him too
the press needs to report what we're
going to put on a screen it says this is
CIA policy in the case of former
directors the agency holds their
security clearance and renews it every
five years for the rest of their lives
however that requires former CIA
directors to behave like current CIA
employees now what you just saw does
that seem like the behavior of a
currency I am ploy II saying what he
just said calling the President of the
United States a traitor in this no way
undermines the CIA's mission really what
about him politicizing intelligence as
an employee of NBC that's pretty
acceptable for a current CIA employee I
don't think so and that brings us to the
well-known leaker and liar himself James
clapper remember he's the former
Director of National Intelligence widely
believed to have leaked details of the
infamous dossier to CNN where he's now
employed fake news and yet CNN just
can't imagine why such an honorable
person like him what loses security
clearance let's take a look
CNN national security analyst James
clapper and given the partisan attacks
on him I just want to take a moment and
walk you through his ample non-partisan
resume served as Director of National
Intelligence during the Obama
administration before that as director
of the Defense Intelligence Agency under
the first president Bush and Bill
Clinton general clapper joined the Air
Force in 1963 served two tours of combat
during the Vietnam War is the recipient
of an Air Force Distinguished Service
Medal to defense distinguished service
medals and three distinguished service
medals for National Intelligence okay
Anderson it was James clapper who issued
a directive that quote in case you want
to do some real research and news on
your station when it is determined that
access to
classified information is no longer
required the department or agency shall
terminate such access and debrief the
individual oh that's James clapper
signature he signed that in 2013 amazing
piece of information
it was clapper who was at the center of
the Obama administration's effort to
scrub the clearance list in order to
avoid leaking but of course no medium
meltdown over that action and as we
stated it was James clapper who likely
leaked the classified information to the
media in order to yeah rigged the
election years after he authored and
signed that quote memo unauthorized
disclosures he said of classified
information including leaks of
classified information to the media
endanger vital intelligence sources and
methods and damaged international
relationships aggressive action is
required to better equip the United
States government elements to prevent
unauthorized disclosures so it's clear
that people like clapper and Brennan and
many other deep state sycophants they
should in no way none of them have any
access to our government secrets as a
matter of fact we ought they ought to
all be under investigation because
they're bias is so abusive clouded their
judgment they are the ones that stomped
on the rights of the American people
they're the ones that tried to
propagandize dis inform the American
people all to affect an election and to
this day they still are and to this day
breaking their own government policies
that they signed off on every American
tonight you need to demand that they not
only lose their special government
privileges but they need to be held
accountable for their blatant abuse of
power by the way Robert Muller are you
watching do you have your people
watching because this is your Russia
Russia Russia Russia collusion story and
by the way Jeff Sessions where are you
has anyone seen you except for school
children all right let's shift gears
let's turn our attention to the ha
the regime of Iran over the weekend the
president issued a stern warning to the
rogue state tweeting quote to the
President of Iran rouhani he said never
ever threaten the u.s. again or you will
suffer consequences the likes of which
few throughout history have ever
suffered before we are no longer a
country that will stand for your
demented words of violence and death be
cautious now per usual this tweet set
off yes predictable widespread
breathless panic from your left-wing
media shocking take a look he criticized
several times Barack Obama and said you
just wait he's gonna start a war with
Iran if it feels like he's on the
political ropes and so that's in his
head with any previous president if
you'd woken up to this all-caps tweet
threatening or with iran you think he
probably belongs in a padded cell but
with trump this is kind of business as
normal Russia just dominated the
conversation for the whole week and he
was hurting so let's distract with a new
topic and in this case it's Iran let's
find the new foil that maybe all of us
will focus on and we'll forget that
there was a summit and how thinking last
week but this strengthens them for Hani
for the foreign minister this makes them
look tough people are rallying around
them so this is actually strengthening
the regime I mean it is a classic move
by President Trump to try to distract
and we've seen this time and time again
when things aren't going well you you
lob a Molotov cocktail in one corner of
the room and everyone runs over there
and now remember these are the same
people claiming the Trump was going to
cause World War three because of his
tough rhetoric against Kim Jong on
little Rocketman fire in fury
our buttons bigger than yours and works
now despite the neverending panic from
his critics President Trump continued
his tough talk against the hostile
Iranian regime take a look I withdrew
the United States from the horrible
one-sided Iran nuclear deal
and Iran is not the same country anymore
that I can say and we'll see what
happens but we're ready to make a real
deal not the deal that was done by the
previous administration which was a
disaster all right someone needs to
remind the corrupt media Obama is gone
and the era of apology tours and
appeasement is now over no longer will
the United States of America sit idly by
as the Iranian regime is fighting proxy
wars chanting death to America
disrupting the entire Middle East and
funding terrorism throughout the world
and of course aggressively pursuing
nuclear weapons and threatening all of
our allies and this country America buns
never allowed these lunatics to develop
nuclear weapons all options must always
remain on the table and while the
president puts a ran on notice he is
also focusing on a critical part of our
national security right here at home
earlier today he had very tough words
for Democrats that literally want to
eliminate ice in other words protection
of our southern borders wide open
borders are they serious
take a look but Democratic politicians
want to abolish ice they want to see
open borders can you imagine you know
every once in a while you'll hear
something and usually you understand
like in deal make and you always have to
understand the other side when you hear
open borders when you hear get rid of
ice when you hear some of the things
that they're proposing it's like you
can't even understand it can you imagine
open borders you'd have millions of
people pouring into our country
millions and millions of people many
people that you don't want in our
country but you would have millions of
people pouring into our country the
crime would be unbelievable and they
want to get rid of the crimefighter on
top of everything else open the border
and get rid of your crime fighters you
don't understand it nobody understands
it all right with the 2018 midterms just
a few short
months away it's clear that Democrats in
this country have no real plan to
approve America instead they want to
regain power in order to take more more
money in other words they want their
crumbs back they want to take back to
the Trump tax cuts they want to impeach
President Trump they want to preserve
the disaster of Obamacare open borders
stop Cavanaugh and they obviously have
we have a new addition to our list they
want to kill off all these legitimate
investigations into what really happened
during the 2016 election the Obama era
deep state corruption the rigging of an
election the rigging of an investigation
now tonight we have bad news for the
Democrats and everyone else actively
working against President Trump look at
this Gallup poll President Trump has hit
the highest approval rating of his
presidency and according to the hill 3/4
of Americans will never vote for a
socialist it should be 99.9% but we'll
get that another night I'll say it again
this is the most important midterm
elections in our lifetime make your
voices heard the future of this country
our rights and future as a
constitutional republic are at stake